hello everyone thank you for tuning in
to the Lange focus channel my name is
Paul today's topic is the FSI free
courses that are available online so
what is the FSI that is the Foreign
Service Institute and that is where
American diplomats or foreign service
workers do their intensive language
training before they are placed abroad
now why does that matter to us to
language learners well it's because the
FSI materials at least the older FSI
materials that they use for their
intensive language study are available
in the public domain and you can get
them on the internet for free so that's
very relevant to us anything that's free
makes us pay a close attention doesn't
it
well you can also get them in hard copy
format you can get some repackaged
versions like this this one is called
mastering Hebrew but this is actually
the FSI Hebrew course just some some
entrepreneur repackage them and decided
to sell it I also have this one
mastering French and I have this one
which is called Welch's Saudi Arabic
this is the Saudi Arabic course from the
FF ad so you can buy them in hard copy
format if you are willing to spend some
money if you want free one or if you
want to try them then their public
domain find them on the internet and
I'll give you a link where you can find
them later so let's talk a little bit
about the pros and cons of these FSI
materials first of all the pros the
first thing is they're free so how can
you go wrong with free materials even if
they suck then you stop using them and
you've lost nothing right so you can
download them try them out see how I go
is they're free
what more could you ask for the second
thing is that they are quite dense
courses there is quite a lot of material
that you can use that you can get
through there the Hebrew one is about
550 pages the French one well this is
only one quarter of it right here on
this in this volume but this is 250
pages all together it's 900 or a
thousand pages and the Arabic one is 250
pages so there's quite a lot of material
for you to use and there's hours and
hours of audio to go with it so it's
just a lot that you can use if you do
work through that material you'll gain a
good working knowledge of the language
it will probably also be very good for
your sentence level fluency because they
just drilled the hell out of you there
are
many drills in these courses there are
question-and-answer drills substitution
drills transformation drills just drills
drills drills not all the time but a lot
of the time and it really helps you just
spit out the sentences more quickly it
really helps improve your fluency and to
produce sentences on the go when you
need to so you don't have to spend as
much thinking time to produce your
sentences after finishing the FSI Hebrew
course there was a huge jump in my
fluency I could produce sentences much
more rapidly I actually studied with the
FSI course between two trips to the
Middle East on the first trip I couldn't
really produce sentences very quickly
and on my second trip there after using
the FSI course everybody told me wow you
speak like a native speaker I guess
they're flattering me a little bit but
basically doing so many drills helped me
to speak fluently and without a lot of
pausing and hesitation they're also good
because the language presented is based
on everyday common situation things like
meeting someone for the first time
ordering a ticket at the station
inviting someone out that kind of thing
talking about the weather those are the
way they introduce the language at the
beginning of the lessons and then after
that they expand upon that by drilling
the hell out of you but they introduced
the language using those common
situations so everything you learn is
quite useful and relevant and it's
thematically based in each chapter so if
that helps you remember all of the new
material you're learning now for the
cons were the bad these courses are
mind-numbingly boring at least some of
them and at least at times they can be
really really drill intensive and I
remember sitting there in the middle of
these courses sometimes just counting
down the minutes a attend more minutes
10 more minutes I'm almost done and just
praying for the end because they really
are boring you need to be motivated
yourself these courses will not motivate
you they're really dry a lot of the time
and you just have to push through them
and that requires you to bring your own
motivation to the table another downside
is that the audio materials are just not
that high-quality because they were
produced in the 1960s and 70s quite a
long time ago and the new CDs that you
might get are still based on those
original master tapes so sometimes
they're not clear they're a bit fuzzy
and they're just not really a they're
not really as good of a model as a
digital audio recording would be a
modern recording so
I would recommend that if you do use
these FS on materials you get some other
more modern digitally recorded audio
materials so that you can copy the
pronunciation of a native speaker
clearly right another downside is that
these courses are not really made to be
used as standalone materials they're
made to be a manual for a classroom
course that is taught by an instructor
an instructor in these courses is
supposed to give you extra activities
that help you get more interactive
experience and sometimes in some of the
books you can see notes to the
instructor like please do this please
prepare an activity for this purpose and
that kind of thing but obviously those
activities are not in the book they were
up to the instructor of the classroom
course so these book don't come with a
classroom course you have to get that
experience that extra component that the
teacher would be responsible for you
have to get done on your own so really
you need to just get experienced
communicating and interacting with
native speakers you need to take some
lessons you need to talk with friends
who speak that language just do that in
addition to these courses so in
conclusion most people find these FSI
courses really just too boring to drill
intensive but I do marginally recommend
them for people who are just having
trouble with fluency and having trouble
with sentence structure people who take
a long time to think about their
sentences and piece them together if you
want to gain that automaticity that
fluency then you want to practice with
some drills these are really good for
drills that's basically the main thing I
recommend them for if you want to just
be able to spit out sentences more
quickly then by all means try these out
check out their drills but bring your
own motivation to the table because
these courses are boring and also just
be prepared for some unclear audio don't
expect 2015 level audio quality because
you won't get it
so supplement with some other audio that
you can model your pronunciation
after thank you for tuning in to the
Lang focused Channel have a good night
talk to you later something that has
been all the rage recently something
called duolingo now this is a totally
free language learning platform it has a
online desktop version and also a
smartphone version it's quite good I
like it but I think it's quite expensive
and that seems to be one of the common
complaints is just the price